có các quy định về hệ thống phân phủ săng rau chủ động thực hiện các giải pháp điều hành giá săng rau trong nước,
bạm sát dễ biển giá thế giới, sự dụng hiểu qua quy định ông giá săng rau bao đam đủ
một công quyền liệu e-tanoan emo chăm để phát triếng săng emu ở vải năm.
Cô mạnh hưởng đến hoạt động của các nhà máy sản xuất săng xin học,
đồng thời bảo đam tính độ các dữ an năng lượng trong niệm.
Trước đó, văn phòng chính phủ cũng có công văn mấy 8 xo hai,
nếu ý kiến chỉ đạo của họ thu tưởng thường trực phạm ra tốt,
về các giải pháp đảng bảo công ứng lủ săng rau cho săng xuất kinh giói và tiêu dụng.
Trong đó, bộ công thường được yêu cầu trụ chỉ theo dõi sát,
dễ biển thiệt trường săng rau thế giới với trong nước.
Chủ đồng đánh giá tình hình cũng cầu dữ trước và hoạt động của hệ thống phân phủ săng rau.
Nhất là dầu dây anh để chủ đồng thực hiện các giải pháp điều hành phủ hợp
theo thẩm quyền và quy định của pháp lật không để thử hụt,
hất gái của nguồn cùng săng rau, nắp ở nguồn như cầu của nền kinh tế và tiêu dụng của xa hội.
Tìm thời bảo giao để xuất tấp có thập quyền,
lùa về các nội dụng và thập quyền.